you did it again clearly i'm a big fan
of sinister and now you and scott are
two for two in the horror realm together
i love it
i appreciate that
i mean it all right so first up here we
don't necessarily need this but i was
especially impressed in the movie by how
not explaining away the grabber's
backstory just it worked exceptionally
well so it was making me wonder are
there any particular details you came up
with for the character that we don't
necessarily see or hear in the film but
are heavily informing how you carry
yourself in the role
i try to you try to give yourself a back
story but but like you
one of the things i really liked about
the script is it doesn't have a ton of
exposition it's like
the guy is clearly broken malevolent and
terrible and
when you're doing things like hurting
children i don't really care about the
reason d you know i the actor need to
know a reason what makes him laugh why
does he
do x and not why why like what is it
that makes him violent versus kind and
what does he think is kind and you can
kind of
you know your imagination you're forced
into i have to think about what that
phone means to me and how this whole
thing started and all that but what i
like about the movie is that it doesn't
tell you what they are because it it
you're experiencing it the way mason
experiences it which is he doesn't know
and so you and even the mask itself
makes your brain just hunt for what you
can't even see what this guy looks like
so you're hunting for any piece of
information that you can find i am
usually world building obsessed so i get
very hung up on those things so when i
walked out i just i couldn't believe how
effective that was where i wasn't being
weighted down by not knowing and instead
it was enhancing the experience bringing
up the masks here i know when you first
read the script you imagined there being
just one mask so what exactly were you
picturing day one when you joined the
project and then how did the masks
evolve and influence your impression of
the character
based on mike's previous experience with
scott on sinister i gave him
a tremendous amount of trust i know
how obsessive he is and how much smarter
he is about this world and this
environment than i am
and
so
i didn't really know and i asked a lot
of questions about the mask and i was
confused by the answers and it wasn't
until i saw them
that i really i knew
how to play the part
i i found it absolutely
fascinating that there were like eight
different versions of the mask you know
they
and we could pick different ones for
different scenes and
[Music]
scott had a logic to it all that was
the logic of a mad person
you know it there wasn't necessarily an
exact rhyme or reason it was just his
own broken mechanism
trying to communicate in his own broken
way
uh
and the mask made him
real for me in some strange way was like
he's ashamed of himself
and
and that shame is driving him to even
more unimaginable
crimes
uh
and that duality was confusing in a good
way
you know it had the the logic of
a human logic to it which is like it
doesn't make any sense at all
and i just i really trusted him but this
person who designed the mask did a great
job the texture on them is amazing and
strange and everything about it
creeped me out it's an iconic look now
too i wouldn't be surprised if we see a
lot of them popping up halloween
i bet we will
um please tell me everything about
working with mason he is absolutely
exceptional in this movie so what was it
about him that you really appreciated as
a scene partner
it's so hard movies love young people
and
the problem with it is it's
really difficult to find a young person
who's capable of carrying a movie like
this
who
loves movies enough who is expressive
enough who can throw themselves over to
it
i recently watched et again you just
like
that's a great film and everything but
henry thomas's performance is just
staggering
and
mason does such a good job and
i knew we had our first rehearsal via
zoom you know because it was in the
heart of the pandemic and everything i
just love the way he thinks and he gave
himself over to it just completely and
the thing about scary movies that you
wouldn't think is a lot of fun to make
it was so it was really playful and
silly
and it's it you you feel like you're
i don't know the best sense of acting
when it really is at play you know the
players where they're playing
and and kids when they're good they're
really game but i knew the movie would
only be as good as he was i mean you
know my performance is lost if
i if he's not exceptional in the movie
because he's
got a big job to do
uh he is
except both of them him and madeline are
phenomenal in this totally before i i
think i still have time for one more
before they make me leave here um so is
there anything about working opposite
mason in terms of him being a fresh set
of eyes someone who is a little bit
newer to the business that maybe
illuminated something in your own craft
that you have yet to tap into
really what it what's hard as you get
older is
keeping your curiosity alive because
curiosity is what's going to take you to
someplace new and being on a set with a
person who is so grateful to be there
and like cherish the experience of
getting to do this scene and
was game to scream or cry or laugh or
be cool or all of the above
at any given moment that
kind of joy of playing is contagious
um
and it makes you throw off your vet and
veteran hard hat and just kind of play
and then life becomes fun again i love
it that's what this is all about you got
to have that kind of mentality if you're
going to stay in this business and keep
making challenging films like this yeah
yeah exactly